[Musik]
das savi und hier online muss man so alt
mit großer sorge inzwischen prüfen ein
was haben user
[Musik]
von problemen inzwischen
endlich wird am 4 haye kann ich die
letzte ja ich hab ja und nein
das video nicht übel zu ja
[Musik]
hoenig und zu ist es wieder entstanden
dass wir zuerst einmal gedreht dann habe
ich diesen trend trotz gestreckt ist bei
dem nationalen trend dieses arbeitet
meinen 37 hotel direkt das heißt die
ganzen trocken und muskeln und diese
einzelnen gelenke eingestellt damit ich
die möglichst wenig zu animieren kann
dann habe ich in allen animiert das
pulver auch in die hier ist und um das
möglichst beste machen halt das
teilweise am eigenen beispiel einfach
von mir gehen
hintergrund sehen können daher wurde die
animation gerendert auf das wichtige
filme gemacht grünen die augen und alles
mögliche und bio und das ganze wieder
jetzt auch drei wochen gedauert
dabei geholfen hat mir einmal wie sophie
das ist die da egal jetzt auch einen
eigenen kanal also hier vorbei die
machen richtig gerade videos der
beschreibung und ausgehalten hatte
sebastian der kanadier hatten wir
deshalb auch ein foto und sowie check in
zu viel aus und wenn ihr auto
die leiste der digitalen funktionen
geben dann kann ich heute mit dem streit
anzufangen dafür sind ein schnitt
gemacht werden findet ihr ein video
beschreibung und damit lärm leiden
unseres meganisi und das ist auch für
anfänger und und weil das video wirklich
so gut auch wenn ich war nicht richtig
stolz auf den würde ich mich freuen wenn
das heim bilden freund otto wurde
irgendwie schicken würde ja schreibt ihr
gerne in die kommentare weil das angebot
mit den funktionen hätte gerne mal mit
allen majors alltag sehen würde und dann
melde mich auf diese weise begleiten
möchte dann abonniere diesen kanal und
dann sehen was am ende hatten
[Musik]